phase four of the MCU will see the
return of Thor and Doctor Strange along
with brand new cinematic versions of
shang-chi and the Eternals but with all
these new faces showing up not everyone
is going to make it out of phase four
alive here are the MCU characters who
probably won't survive phase four red
Guardian has a pretty complicated
history with Black Widow in the comics
they're married until he fakes his death
in order to train with the KGB to become
a mask wearing super soldier beyond his
history with Natasha Red Guardian is
perhaps best known for being the Soviet
Union's answer to Captain America right
down to having his own big shield
considering that the MCU has a long
history of changing comic book
characters to fit a little better into
the cinematic universe we're willing to
bet that beyond a complicated history
with Black Widow Red Guardian won't be
much like his comic book counterpart
from what we've seen - the Black Widow
movie we're predicting that David
harbors red Guardian will be playing
less of a husband and more of a father
figure - the Black Widow if that's true
you can pretty much bet the farm that he
won't be making it out of his first
movie alive let alone the rest of phase
4 it's pretty rare for any father figure
to live to see the closing credits in a
superhero movie at all period just ask
Uncle Ben Thomas Wayne and Tony Stark
considering that the Black Widow movie
is actually a prequel that will take
place immediately following the events
of Captain America Civil War on accounts
of Black Widow currently be dead in the
MCU it seems even less likely that
harbors red Guardian will appear in the
series pass this film Iron Man 3 took
comic book fans on a journey by
completely reimagining the Mandarin one
of Iron Man's oldest and most well-known
foes
then Kingsley's interpretation of the
villain was not what anyone familiar
with the character was expecting and it
turns out that was on purpose
in reality the Mandarin was Trevor
Slattery a British actor with a
dedication to the craft and few scruples
about playing a fake terrorist on TV
then they approached me about the role
and then you about the drugs whether
they should they'd get you off him said
they'd give me more however in all hail
the king a marvel short film it's
revealed that the Mandarin isn't quite
as fictional as Slattery believed in
fact the Mandarin and his organization
the ten rings are very real and very
angry at Slattery the short ends with
the actor being kidnapped by one of the
ten rings a storyline that's been left
unaddressed since 2014 was shang-chi and
The Legend of the ten
things on the way it's the perfect time
to address that unresolved plot how
exactly it will be addressed as unknown
we know the real Mandarin will be in the
upcoming film but whether or not the
fake will be making a cameo is still a
well-kept secret either way if he
actually appears on screen or if he's
just mentioned offhand it's pretty
unlikely we'll see Slattery pop up again
in the MCU past phase 4 no we haven't
forgotten that the ancient one bit the
magic bullet way back in 2016 stocker
strange that said since when is a
character's death really kept them from
coming back especially when that
character is played by the inimitable
Tilda Swinton as we saw an Avengers
endgame when the Hulk ran into a past
version of the ancient one Swinton seems
very game to reprise her role whenever
possible
add in the fact that Doctor Strange is
one character for whom the laws of
reality rarely seemed to apply and it's
easy to imagine Swinton making yet
another appearance and Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness there are
plenty of opportunities to bring back
the ancient one to interact with the
sorcerer supreme nightmare for instance
has been rumored to be the villain and a
super villain with the power to bring
your fears to life could manifest some
terrifying version of the ancient one to
tell strange all the ways he's failed to
live up to her expectations or with
other rumors hinting that the sequel
will feature dimension-hopping strange
could run into an alternate universe
version of his former mystic master
giving Swinton a chance to reinvent the
character she's played twice already it
seems likely that we'll see some sort of
cathartic confrontation between the two
masters of the mystic arts that doesn't
mean we can expect a full resurrection
for the ancient one her death in the
first Doctor Strange was an integral
emotional feat for everyone involved and
bringing her back again past phase 4
would retroactively Lee damaged the film
Tilda Swinton appears in Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness you can
expect it to be her swan song as with
plenty of other characters in the MCU
the helmet Zemo we met in Captain
America Civil War wasn't quite a
faithful adaptation of his comics
counterpart instead of the Nazi
aristocrat who hates Steve Rogers with a
passion Daniel Bruhl conception of the
character was a melancholy soul who puts
the events of Civil War in action as
revenge for his family's death in
sokovia his character arcs seem more or
less complete in that film since his
revenge was achieved while T'Challa
seeing the kind of man that Zemo had
become in search of vengeance chose to
be better that's why it was a bit of a
suprise
to see that Brule would be reprise in
the role for the upcoming Disney Plus
show the Falcon in the Winter Soldier
Zemo might a framed Bucky for murder
once upon a time but the Winter Soldier
in the Falcon were both completely
absent during the battle at sokovia and
Avengers age of Ultron so the two heroes
are a strange target for further
vengeance regardless while the
comic-book character has a long and
storied history it's very difficult to
imagine the MCU Zemo starting up the
Masters of evil or disguising himself as
a superhero as the leader of the
Thunderbolts whatever zimos role in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier might be
it's very unlikely that we'll see him
pop up again past spades or check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]